A while back, I was in a taxi. The driver was a man named Ali Youssef. He has this pretty music playing on the tape deck, though the tape was a little on the warbly side. So at some point I asked him, what is the music? What is that? And he said, well, that's the music from his country, which, if I remember right, was Somalia. We talked for a while. And then he says to me, that's my wife. I say, really? And he says, yeah. She's still back in Africa. She's a singer at weddings, and like that. And he was here, and she was there. And he would drive around all day in his taxi, listening to her sing, hour after hour, on the road, thinking about her, missing her.
不久前，我坐了一次出租车。司机名叫阿里·优素福。他的磁带播放器里放着优美的音乐，虽然磁带听起来有点走调。所以，在某个时候我问他，这是什么音乐？那是什么？他说，那是他祖国的音乐，如果我没记错的话，那是索马里。我们聊了一会儿。然后他对我说，那是我的妻子。我说，真的吗？他说，是的。她还在非洲。她是那里的婚礼歌手，诸如此类。他在这里，而她在那里。他整天开着出租车四处奔波，在路上听着她唱的歌，一小时又一小时，想着她，思念她。
I picture him out there on the road right now, his tape playing, just one of the many people on the road right now. So much of the life of this country happens in cars. So much of it. Imagine for a moment that you could look down on all the streets and avenues and windy country roads and highways from above somehow, highway cloverleafs in a vast meadow spread before you. Each little car below its own little self-contained world, each one like its own little world when you go inside. In one, a high school sophomore tries to convince her boyfriend, Tony, and his friend, Milo, to buy tickets to the prom.
我能想象出他此刻就在路上，播放着磁带，他只是此刻路上众多行人中的一个。这个国家很大一部分生活是在车里发生的。很大一部分。想象一下，如果你能从上方俯瞰所有的街道、大道、蜿蜒的乡间小路和高速公路，高速公路的立交桥就像一片铺展在你面前的巨大草地。下面每一辆小车都是一个独立的世界，当你走进去时，每一辆车都像是一个小世界。在其中一辆车里，一个高二女生正试图说服她的男友托尼和他的朋友米洛购买舞会门票。
Tony, pay for prom.
托尼，付钱参加舞会吧。
I'll get some money.
我会弄到钱的。
Tony says he's broke, though he's about to spend over $100 on the paint job for the car.
托尼说他没钱，尽管他打算花100多美元给车做喷漆。
I want to go to prom. I got a dress, too. I got three.
我想去参加舞会。我也买了礼服。我有三件。
You do.
你有吗。
Tony turns to his friend.
托尼转向他的朋友。
Because I'd like to take her out.
因为我想带她出去。
No! Tony, you're going to regret this for this rest of his life if he doesn't.
不！托尼，如果你不这么做，你余生都会后悔的。
Yeah, you would?
是啊，你会吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
Trust me, because I'm regretting the date up to here.
相信我，因为我现在对这次约会后悔得要命。
Meanwhile, in a four-door white 1991 Honda Accord, Lauren Burn is speeding through San Francisco. It's part of her job. Her trunk's all smashed, tied down with rope. She's been rear-ended twice. The car floor is cluttered with empty Mountain Dew bottles and discarded packs of cigarettes. On the door of the car, a sign's attached, "Lickety-Split Messengers."
与此同时，在一位四门白色1991年本田雅阁车里，劳伦·伯恩正在旧金山超速行驶。这是她工作的一部分。她的后备箱撞坏了，用绳子捆着。她已经被追尾两次了。车内地板上堆满了空的山露饮料瓶和丢弃的烟盒。车门上贴着一个标志：“Lickety-Split 快递”。
Whoa, red light. Every car's relationship to me is definitely they don't like me. They hate me because I think they're really scared and paranoid about, like, driving with no hands, talking on my radio, and next, at the same time, trying to write something down, trying to look for an address. And I look at it as a big video game. You have so much time to pick something up and drop something off in this time. And then you have all these obstacles in between, kind of like Paperboy, like the old video game. You know what I'm saying? Yeah, I've hit a few fire hydrants and a few people and a few different cars. And you get points taken off for that, I must say. Dude, I totally am going the wrong way.
哇，红灯。每辆车对我的态度肯定都是他们不喜欢我。他们讨厌我，因为我认为他们真的很害怕，对那种不把手放在方向盘上、对着无线电说话，同时又试图写下东西、寻找地址的驾驶方式感到神经质。我把它看作是一个大型电子游戏。你在这一段时间里有这么多时间去接东西和送东西。然后在中间你有所有这些障碍，有点像《派送员》，就像那个老式电子游戏。你知道我在说什么吗？是的，我撞过几个消防栓、几个人和几辆不同的车。我必须说，你会因为这些被扣分。伙计，我完全走错路了。
In a year-old Chrysler 300M, Doris Kelly drives from a long day at work downtown, towards church, playing the CD that she plays every night after work on the way home, one her pastor recommended, one they play in church, called Spirit Songs .
在一辆一年前买的克莱斯勒300M车里，多丽丝·凯利在市中心忙碌了一天后开车去教堂，播放着她每天下班回家路上都会听的CD，那是她的牧师推荐的，他们在教堂里也放，名字叫《灵歌》。
[WORSHIP MUSIC]
[礼拜音乐]
People don't have peace. People don't have any joy. And they need that. And you see that driving on the expressways and driving on the streets. And people, you know, they're cutting in and out in front of you all the time, and honking horns and yelling at you, cursing and stuff. And if you listen to this kind of tape, you're calm, you're relaxed. You stop. You let people in. To me, it's equal to a martini that someone would go home and have a martini, relax.
人们没有平静。人们没有任何喜悦。他们需要那个。你在高速公路上和街道上开车时就能看到这一点。人们，你知道，他们一直都在你面前加塞，按喇叭，对你大喊大叫，咒骂等等。如果你听这种磁带，你会很冷静，很放松。你会停下来。你会让别人先行。对我来说，这等同于一杯马提尼，有人回家喝杯马提尼，放松一下。
You look like you need a drink, she said. He sat with his head in his hands, in a pale bleached oak armchair beneath a pastel seascape framed in ash.
“你看上去需要喝一杯，”她说。他双手抱头坐在那里，坐在一张铺着白色漂白橡木扶手椅上，下方是一幅镶在白蜡木框里的淡色海景画。
In a navy blue Toyota Celica, Marlene Harris listens to one of the books on tape that she's in the middle of, a science fiction novel called Darwin's Radio. She loves books on tape.
在海军蓝丰田赛利卡车里，玛琳·哈里斯正在听她读到一半的有声读物，那是一部名为《达尔文电台》的科幻小说。她很喜欢有声读物。
The secondary mucus plug seems to be in position. There was no trauma, no bleeding. The separation was textbook, if anybody has bothered to write a textbook about this sort of thing. The hospital did a quick biopsy. It's definitely a first-stage Shiva rejection.
次级粘液栓似乎就位了。没有外伤，没有出血。分离是教科书式的，如果有人费心写过关于这种事情的教科书的话。医院做了一个快速活检。这绝对是第一阶段的湿婆排斥反应。
I'm wonder how this is going to come out. I'm thinking that the government's wrong and that Kaye Lang is right, and that her baby's going to be born alive. I do not think it's going to cause massive diseases. But I have a feeling they may start a colony, the mothers and fathers of these children.
我不知道这会如何发展。我在想政府是错的，而凯·朗是对的，她的孩子会活着出生。我不认为这会导致大规模的疾病。但我有一种预感，他们可能会建立一个殖民地，这些孩子的母亲和父亲们。
Let's hope. We'll do more tests in a few months.
希望如此。我们几个月后再做更多测试。
I'm partly in another world, not the parts that need to be driving a car. But I get very involved in the stories. I often listen to very involved things. I'm in the middle of a 20-book historical fiction series that takes place during the Napoleonic Wars, and takes place in the British navy. And I'm about to start book 14. And I talk about going out for a walk with Jack and Steven, who are the two main characters of this series, because by the time it's over I will have spent something like 300 hours with these guys.
我有一部分进入了另一个世界，不是那些需要开车的部分。但我非常沉浸在故事中。我经常听一些非常深入的东西。我正在读一个20本书的系列历史小说，故事发生在拿破仑战争期间，在英国海军中。我快要开始读第14本了。我谈论和杰克与史蒂文去散步，他们是这个系列的主角，因为等它结束时，我大概会花上300个小时和这些家伙在一起。
If you're on the road right now in your car, listening to the radio, take a look inside the cars around you, each one its own little bubble, its own tiny subculture on wheels, glass and steel worlds rolling down the street alongside each other. Today on our radio program, we take you inside those other cars on the road. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass.
如果你现在正在车里开车，听着收音机，看看你周围的车，每一辆都是一个独立的气泡，一个车轮上的微型亚文化，玻璃和钢铁的世界并排在街上滚动。今天在我们的广播节目中，我们带你进入路上那些其他的车里。来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Today on our show, we have lots of tape recorded inside moving vehicles, plus original stories by Nick Hornby and David Sedaris. We have parents and kids. We have longtime buddies drinking beer and cruising the neighborhood on a Sunday morning. We have drivers who save people, and drivers who do not want to be saved. The entire American road system is laid out before us, and let's start right in Chicago, on Chicago Avenue, where the Number 66 bus runs.
在今天的节目中，我们有很多在移动车辆中录制的磁带，还有尼克·霍恩比和大卫·塞达里斯的原创故事。我们有父母和孩子。我们有老友在周日早晨喝着啤酒在社区里兜风。我们有拯救他人的司机，也有不想被拯救的司机。整个美国道路系统都在我们面前展开，让我们从芝加哥开始，在66路公交车经过的芝加哥大道上。
Come on, boo, come on. How you doing? Come along, now.
快点，宝贝，快点。你好吗？来吧，现在。
Hello.
你好。
See, you made me miss my light.
看，你害我错过了绿灯。
I'm sorry.
对不起。
But that's OK.
没关系。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
[模糊的短语]。
We want to make sure we OK, though.
我们要确保我们没事。
Let's stay here for a while. Linnel Peterson is 40, outgoing. The route she drives, Chicago Avenue, heads from the point where the City of Chicago touches Lake Michigan on the eastern edge of the city out to the western-most edge of the city, a route that is six miles in each direction, so long and slow to drive that in an eight-hour shift she only drives it back and forth four times. She's been a bus driver for six years.
我们在这待一会儿吧。林内尔·彼得森40岁，性格外向。她驾驶的路线，芝加哥大道，从芝加哥市触及密歇根湖的东边缘一直到城市的最西端，每一方向都是六英里，开车又慢又长，所以在八小时的班次中，她只能来回跑四次。她做公交车司机已经六年了。
When I was little, I didn't think you could back a bus up. There was a lot of things. I didn't really think about a bus. OK.
我小的时候，没想过你可以倒着开公交车。有很多事情。我真的没想过公交车。好吧。
What's weird is when you're in your car, and you pull up to a bus stop, and you're getting ready to open the door, and you realize you're in your car. I'm serious. Or like, you know, somebody's running across the street, and you're starting to slow down because, mentally, you've got to pick 'em-- and I was like, OK. Ooh, big truck. He has flammables. I mean, he was flying, right behind us.
奇怪的是，当你在车里，开车到公交车站，准备开门时，你意识到你是在自己的车里。我是认真的。或者像，你知道，有人在过马路，你开始减速，因为在精神上，你得去接他们——我就想，好的。哦，大卡车。他装有易燃物。我是说，他飞驰而过，就在我们后面。
Hi, Mommy.
嗨，妈妈。
Hi baby!
嗨，宝贝！
How you doin?
你好吗？
All right. And you?
挺好。你呢？
Good. That's my mommy. That's my mother, right there.
挺好。那是我的妈妈。就在那儿，那是我的母亲。
What's happening?
发生什么了？
Nothing.
没什么。
[INAUDIBLE]?
[听不清]？
Yes, ma'am.
是的，女士。
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
OK. Bye, Mommy. There are times that I've picked her up, and people get on the bus, and I'm like, that's my mommy, everybody. And they're laughing at me, because I still call her Mommy and I'm 40.
好吧。再见，妈妈。有时候我接她，有人上车，我就说，那是我的妈妈，大家。他们会笑我，因为我40岁了还叫她妈妈。
Central Park, this is where I grew up at. Two blocks from here. My mom still lives down there. Watch your step. Have a good one. Two, exactly two blocks from here. And this is why I say, this is our bus route, going to school and-- because I went to Orr. And anything that we did, right here in this vicinity. Lydell.
中央公园，这是我长大的地方。离这儿两个街区。我妈妈还住在下面。小心台阶。祝你有愉快的一天。两个，离这儿正好两个街区。这就是为什么我说，这是我们的公交路线，去上学——因为我去了奥尔高中。我们做的任何事，就在这附近。莱德尔。
The grammar school I went to is a block down there. That's one of the neatest about being in a neighborhood. There are times when I see people who went to school with me, and they'll get on the bus. And I was like, I know you. Didn't you graduate from Orr? Or something like that. Like I'm saying, that's like a 23-year-ago thing. Central is next. Have a good one, baby.
我上的小学在下面一个街区。这是在一个社区里最整洁的事情之一。有时候我看到和我一起上学的人，他们会上车。我就想，我认识你。你不是从奥尔高中毕业的吗？或者是类似的事情。就像我说的那样，那是23年前的事情了。下一站是中央街。祝你有愉快的一天，宝贝。
You, too. You too, darling.
你也是。你也是，亲爱的。
Thank you, baby. Watch your step. It used to be real nice where we grew up at. And it's like really drug-infested now. When we first moved over there, it was like a lot of Polish people that lived in the area. And that was about 30 years ago, when we first moved there, because I was about 10. Now it's only blacks. You might find a few.
谢谢，宝贝。小心台阶。我们长大的地方曾经真的很不错。现在真的全是毒品。当我们刚搬到那里时，那个地区住着很多波兰人。那是大约30年前，当我们刚搬到那里时，因为我大概10岁。现在只有黑人了。你可能还能找到几个。
OK, when we was in high school-- Hey, babe, step on out. Every so often, like when I pass Kostner, we used to stand outside and wait for the bus. And it would be so many of us, and we were kind of rowdy. The bus driver would kind of pass us up. It would be so funny. Not all the time, but-- Thank you, baby.
好的，当我们上高中的时候——嘿，宝贝，走吧。每隔一段时间，比如当我经过科斯特纳的时候，我们过去常常站在外面等车。我们有很多人，而且有点吵闹。公交车司机过去常常会不停车。那会很有趣。不是一直这样，但是——谢谢，宝贝。
So what happens is, when I get in that area, I kind of just start laughing. People are looking at me, like what's wrong with her? But people will usually ask me, you must be a nut to drive Chicago every day, because it's like a high-traffic area. But then, I think it's the fact that this is where I grew up at and I feel comfortable in it.
所以发生的事情是，当我到达那个区域时，我就会开始笑。人们看着我，好像她怎么了？但人们通常会问我，你每天开芝加哥大道一定是疯了，因为那里是高交通区域。但后来，我想是因为这是我长大的地方，我在那里感到自在。
Linnel Peterson. She says on her days off, she tries to keep away from her route, Chicago Avenue, even though she lives right nearby.
林内尔·彼得森。她说在她休息的日子里，她尽量远离她的路线，芝加哥大道，尽管她就住在附近。
I even avoid coming on the street, just the whole street. Because when I used to, I used to come on Chicago and I would be like, oh, there's a bus. Oh, he's out of place. So you just remember so much from the stuff that happens when you drive out here. Four lanes.
我甚至避免来这条街，整条街。因为当我过去常来的时候，我过去常来芝加哥大道，我会想，哦，那有一辆公交车。哦，他不在位了。所以你会记得太多在你开车经过这里时发生的事情。四条车道。
[MUSIC - "BABY ARE YENG" BY NANCY JACOBS & HER SISTER]
[音乐 - 南希·雅各布斯及其姐妹的《BABY ARE YENG》]
Across the ocean in England, cars are driving along the wrong side of the road, one of them an emerald green four-door car that we would call a Peugeot, but that they would call a Puh-joh. It's driven by Nick Hornby.
在大洋彼岸的英国，汽车在道路的另一侧行驶，其中一辆是翡翠绿色的四门车，我们会称之为标致，但他们会称之为“Puh-joh”。它由尼克·霍恩比驾驶。
So it's a lovely, sunny, crisp London Sunday morning, and I'm in the car with my son, Danny. Danny's six and autistic. And he loves the car. It really is a bubble to him, and nobody can burst it. When he's strapped into the backseat, he's safe. No other kids can get in his face, like they do out in the world where people fly at him like asteroids towards a spacecraft. And nobody will make him eat food he doesn't want to eat, and the side window is a videotape that never needs changing.
所以这是一个可爱、阳光明媚、干爽的伦敦周日早晨，我和我儿子丹尼在车里。丹尼六岁，患有自闭症。他很喜欢车。对他来说，它真的是一个气泡，没人能戳破它。当他被系在后座上时，他是安全的。没有其他孩子能凑到他脸上，不像在外面那个人们像小行星撞向航天器一样飞向他的世界。而且没人会强迫他吃他不想吃的食物，侧窗是一个永远不需要更换的录像带。
He like to know where he's going, though, so he's memorized all the significant routes. This is a kid who only occasionally remembers that the sequence beginning ready and steady is completed by the word "go," but somehow-- and these somehows constitute the enduring mystery of autism-- he's managed to construct a mental street map of the entire London metropolitan area.
不过他喜欢知道他要去哪儿，所以他背下了所有重要的路线。这是一个偶尔才记得以“ready”和“steady”开头的序列是由“go”这个词完成的孩子，但不知何故——而这些“不知何故”构成了自闭症持久的谜团——他成功地构建了整个大伦敦地区的心理街道地图。
The route to school is OK, because he likes school. The route to grandma's house is OK, too, not only because he likes grandma, but because she lives 50-odd miles from London, so he gets to stay in the car longer. The route that's not OK is the route to the park. The park's too close to home, which means that the journey's over before it's properly begun. And someone, a bad person, his dad, will make him get out of the car. But it's a lovely, sunny, crisp Sunday morning. We're going to the park.
去学校的路线是可以的，因为他喜欢学校。去外婆家的路线也可以，不仅因为他喜欢外婆，还因为她住在离伦敦50多英里远的地方，所以他可以在车里待得更久。不去公园的路线是不行的。公园离家太近了，这意味着旅程还没正式开始就已经结束了。而且有人，一个坏人，他的爸爸，会让他下车。但这是一个可爱、阳光明媚、干爽的周日早晨。我们要去公园。
He starts to yell at the top of Delancey street in Camden when we don't turn left into Albany Street. That left turn he sees as his last chance. School was ruled out 10 minutes ago when we didn't turn into Liverpool Road after crossing Holloway Road at Drayton Park. See, Albany Street takes you onto Houston Road, and Houston Road leads eventually to the motorway and grandma's house. But from Delancey Street, we go straight across into Regent's Park Road on our way to Primrose Hill. Doesn't that sound nice, Primrose Hill? Not to Danny it doesn't.
当我们不在卡姆登的德兰西街尽头左转进入奥尔巴尼街时，他开始大叫。他把那个左转视为他最后的机会。学校在10分钟前就被排除了，因为我们在穿过德雷顿公园的霍洛威路后没有转入利物浦路。你看，奥尔巴尼街带你进入休斯顿路，休斯顿路最终通向高速公路和外婆家。但从德兰西街，我们径直穿过进入摄政公园路，前往樱草花山。那听起来不错，不是吗，樱草花山？对丹尼来说可不是。
The yells get louder when we stop, and reach a sweat-inducing pitch when I open his door. Come on, Dan, I say, in my best fun voice. We're going to the park, the swings, the seesaw. He just turns the yellometer up to 11. I try to lead him out by the hand, but he snatches it away and grabs hold of something, the seat belt, anything that will anchor him inside. So we're fighting, the car and I, for custody of this small boy. The car has one end of Danny, and I have the other. The three of us are like a warring family in a TV soap.
当我们停车时，喊叫声变得更大，当我打开他的车门时，达到了让人出汗的音高。快点，丹，我用我最好的快乐声音说。我们要去公园，去荡秋千，玩跷跷板。他只是把“喊叫计”调到了11。我试图牵着他的手把他领出来，但他猛地抽走手，抓住任何东西，安全带，任何能把他固定在里面的东西。所以我们正在战斗，车和我，争夺这个小男孩的监护权。车抓住了丹尼的一端，我抓住了另一端。我们三个就像电视肥皂剧里交战的家庭。
I end up dragging my son out by his ankles. A couple look at us as they walk past. They don't say anything, but one day I'm sure someone's going to report me and I'll be arrested. There's a certain irony to this. I learned to drive at the age of 41, entirely because of Danny. I didn't really want to learn, and I have a mild phobia about driving. But public transport, which had served me well all my adult London life, was becoming less and less fun.
我最终不得不拽着我儿子的脚踝把他拖出来。一对夫妇在走过时看着我们。他们什么也没说，但我敢肯定总有一天会有人举报我，我会被逮捕。这其中有一种讽刺意味。我在41岁时学会了开车，完全是因为丹尼。我并不真的想学，而且我对开车有轻微的恐惧症。但公共交通，在我整个成年伦敦生活中一直服务得很好，变得越来越没意思了。
Danny loves going on trains and buses, of course, but sometimes he didn't want to get off when I wanted to get off, and sometimes he wanted to get off before our stop, and sometimes he decided that he didn't want to wear any trousers on the top deck of the number 19. And though I won all these battles of will, because I'm bigger than him, I wasn't always in the mood to fight them in public.
丹尼当然喜欢坐火车和公交车，但有时我想下车时他不想下车，有时他想在我们到站前下车，有时他决定不想在19路车的顶层穿任何裤子。虽然我赢得了所有这些意志的较量，因为我比他大，但我并不总是想在公共场合进行这些较量。
They can be Pyrrhic victories anyway, these fights with autistic kids. Danny's best friend and classmate, Toby, once kicked up such a fuss about having his haircut at the hairdresser's that he had to be held down by his mom and his nanny, at which point a woman ran over and started pummeling them both with her fists. Sometimes I silently dare someone to say or do something, just so I can tell them why I'm having to be so cruel, and hopefully make them feel terrible in the process.
这些与自闭症儿童的争斗有时可能是皮洛士式的胜利。丹尼最好的朋友兼同学托比，曾经在理发店剪头发时闹得天翻地覆，以至于他不得不被他的妈妈和保姆按住，这时一个女人跑过来，开始用拳头猛击他们两个。有时我默默地希望有人说点什么或做点什么，这样我就可以告诉他们我为什么要这么残忍，并希望让他们在这个过程中感到糟糕。
So anyway, I took driving lessons for 18 months, and slowly, slowly overcame my fear. And nothing, I felt, after every awful, jabbering, fear-filled 60-minute lesson, could've demonstrated more dramatically how much I love my son. I passed my test first time, and I bought a little four-door Peugeot that I thought he'd love, so I could drive him places like the park. And is he grateful? Is he? Hell. He's holding onto his seat belt for dear life and screaming while I try to pull him backwards onto the pavement.
总之，我学了18个月的驾驶课，慢慢地，慢慢地克服了我的恐惧。在每一节糟糕的、喋喋不休的、充满恐惧的60分钟课程之后，我觉得没有什么能比这更能戏剧性地证明我有多爱我的儿子。我第一次就通过了考试，我买了一辆小四门标致，我想他会喜欢的，这样我就可以带他去像公园这样的地方。他感激吗？他感激吗？见鬼。他拼命抓住安全带尖叫，而我试图把他向后拉到人行道上。
Eventually, he can hold on no longer, and I lift him out and put him down. And after a brief pause during which he recovers his composure and stops yelling, he roars off towards the park gates, because another thing Danny's forgotten until this very second is that he loves the park. He loves the swings and the seesaw, and spinning round and round on the grass until he's dizzy.
最终，他再也抓不住了，我把他抱出来放下。在他短暂的停顿，恢复冷静并停止喊叫后，他向公园大门咆哮而去，因为丹尼直到这一秒才想起的另一件事是他热爱公园。他喜欢荡秋千、玩跷跷板，在草地上不停地转圈，直到头晕目眩。
And it's a lovely, sunny, crisp Sunday morning. And hey, there's an empty swing. And literally within 10 seconds, he's full of smiles and happy anticipation. And there's no trace whatsoever in his face of the ankle-pulling trauma to which he was so recently and cruelly subjected.
那是一个可爱、阳光明媚、干爽的周日早晨。嘿，有一个空的秋千。字面上在10秒之内，他就充满了微笑和快乐的期待。他脸上完全没有刚才被我残酷对待而留下的脚踝拉伤的痕迹。
And I want to find the couple who may or may not have had a disapproving look on their faces when they saw me committee awful acts of violence, and show them just how joyful he is now. But of course they're not around, which is maybe just as well, because in a while I'm going to have to find a way to get him out of this swing.
我想找到那对可能或可能没有在看到我实施可怕暴力行为时露出反感表情的夫妇，向他们展示他现在有多快乐。但当然他们不在附近，这也许是件好事，因为过一会儿我就得想办法让他从秋千上下来。
Nick Hornby is the author of High Fidelity and About a Boy .
尼克·霍恩比是《高保真》和《关于一个男孩》的作者。
Back on this side of the Atlantic again, though not very far inland, on Cape Cod. In a green Volvo sedan, Jay Allison drives his daughter, Lily, to ice skating lessons. She's 12, which means-- surprise!-- in the car they do not agree about what radio station to play.
回到大西洋的这一边，虽然离内陆不远，在科德角。在一辆绿色沃尔沃轿车里，杰伊·艾利森开车送他的女儿莉莉去上滑冰课。她12岁，这意味着——惊喜！——在车里，他们对该放哪个电台意见不一致。
Are we going to be late?
我们要迟到了吗？
Uh, probably.
呃，可能吧。
Leigh's going to kill me. She hates me already.
莉要杀了我。她已经讨厌我了。
Why does she hate you?
为什么她讨厌你？
I don't know. Because we're always late.
我不知道。因为我们总是迟到。
We're not always late.
我们不总是迟到。
We usually are.
我们通常是。
Oh, man.
天哪。
Well, you never let me listen. It's not fair.
好吧，你从来不让我听。这不公平。
I always let you listen.
我总是让你听。
Oh my god, are you serious?
天哪，你是认真的吗？
No, seriously. I've lost so many brain cells in this car thanks to you.
不，我是说真的。多亏了你，我在车里损失了太多脑细胞。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
See, there go a few.
看，又损失了几个。
There go a couple more.
又损失了几个。
Really.
真的。
Really?
真的吗？
It's hurting me. It's going into my brain and--
这伤害了我。它进入我的大脑，然后——
It's going into your brain and hurting you?
它进入你的大脑伤害你？
Yes. Ow.
是的。哎哟。
This is Santana. Shouldn't you be gaining?
这是桑塔纳。你不应该在增强吗？
All right, I feel-- Gaining strength from Carlos?
好吧，我觉得——从卡洛斯那里获得力量？
Yep. I love [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
是的。我喜欢[听不清]。
OK, make it stop. Make it go away. No, no, no.
好的，让它停下。让它消失。不，不，不。
That's OK.
没关系。
Kill it.
杀了它。
Thank you.
谢谢。
I've always felt so bad with the Rose, like all those other stations, the good stations.
我一直对罗斯电台感觉很糟，就像所有那些其他电台，好的电台。
What about them?
它们怎么了？
What's so bad about them?
它们有什么不好的？
There's no intelligent life on them.
上面没有智慧生命。
Oh, geez.
哦，天哪。
I'm going to short-circuit your radio so it will only play public radio.
我要把你的收音机短路，这样它只能播放公共广播。
That's sad. I don't know what I'd do. I'd buy a new radio.
那太可悲了。我不知道我会做什么。我会买一个新的收音机。
There are lots of good shows on public radio.
公共广播里有很多好节目。
OK, whatever.
好的，随便吧。
What. Ever.
随。便。
That was cool, Dad. Do that again.
那太酷了，爸爸。再做一次。
Thank you, Lil.
谢谢，莉尔。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
[听不清]。
What, do we get to talk for a few minutes, and then we have to-- It's like you're going to the surface for oxygen?
什么，我们得聊几分钟，然后我们得——就像你要浮出水面呼吸氧气一样？
"Say My Name."
“说出我的名字”。
[MUSIC - "SAY MY NAME" BY DESTINY'S CHILD]
[音乐 - 天命真女的《SAY MY NAME》]
OK, make it stop it. It just hurt me.
好的，让它停下。它刚刚伤害了我。
I'll find a good one.
我会找一个好的。
[MUSIC - "MARIA, MARIA" BY CARLOS SANTANA]
[音乐 - 卡洛斯·桑塔纳的《MARIA, MARIA》]
Here, more Santana. Are you gaining cells?
给你，更多桑塔纳。你的细胞在增强吗？
Santana, Santana's gone over to the dark side a little bit.
桑塔纳，桑塔纳稍微投向了黑暗面。
[MUSIC - "SHOW ME THE MEANING OF BEING LONELY" BY THE BACKSTREET BOYS]
[音乐 - 后街男孩的《SHOW ME THE MEANING OF BEING LONELY》]
They did a remix.
他们做了一个混音版。
A remix? They didn't like the first one?
混音版？他们不喜欢第一版吗？
It wasn't popular enough. It was number one for, like, two days.
不够流行。它在第一位待了大约两天。
What was?
什么是在第一位？
This song. It's like another Backstreet Boys song. And did you know that Kevin Richardson of the Backstreet Boys is engaged?
这首歌。就像另一首后街男孩的歌。你知道后街男孩的凯文·理查森订婚了吗？
Did I know that? Of course I knew that.
我知道吗？我当然知道。
Really?
真的吗？
Oh, sure. His birthday's coming up, isn't it? Kevin's?
哦，当然。他的生日快到了，不是吗？凯文的？
Oh my god. You're so weird.
天哪。你太奇怪了。
[SINGING] I want to love you, baby.
[唱歌] 我想爱你，宝贝。
Oh, god. Please stop, please. Just let me hear this once song, and then you can--
哦，天哪。请停下，请。就让我听这首歌一次，然后你可以——
Yeah, no, I love this song.
是的，不，我喜欢这首歌。
Aren't you embarrassed?
你不尴尬吗？
[SINGING] Everybody sing with me.
[唱歌] 大家和我一起唱。
Dad, stop. Stop it, Dad.
爸爸，停下。停下，爸爸。
What? So maybe the secret is I should start liking your music.
什么？所以也许秘诀是我应该开始喜欢你的音乐。
No, that would be really bad.
不，那会很糟糕。
Yes.
是的。
No, I'll just keep it off. It's OK.
不，我还是关掉吧。没关系。
Seriously, we're going to listen to public radio in a minute. Are you ready? Here we go.
说真的，我们过一会儿就要听公共广播了。你准备好了吗？我们开始吧。
Dad.
爸爸。
Here we go, listen. Listen and learn, sweetheart.
我们开始吧，听。听好了，学会吧，亲爱的。
You're listening to NPR's Weekend Edition.
你正在收听NPR的周末版。
I know.
我知道。
Now, don't you feel better?
现在，你感觉好点了吗？
The Grammy Awards are Wednesday night.
格莱美奖在周三晚上。
Hey, look, the Grammys.
嘿，看，格莱美奖。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是啊。
And if the conventional wisdom is correct, it will be a big night for the oldest and youngest in rock.
如果传统智慧是正确的，那对于摇滚乐中最年长和最年轻的艺术家来说，将是一个重大的夜晚。
Weekend Edition Popular Culture commentator, Steven Stark. For you all, the night will feature 52-year-old Carlos Santana, who could walk away with--
周末版大众文化评论员史蒂文·斯塔克。对你们所有人来说，那个夜晚将有52岁的卡洛斯·桑塔纳，他可能会带着——
Hey, there he is again.
嘿，他又在那里了。
He's nominated for, like, so many.
他被提名了，像是很多项。
And Album of the Year for Supernatural. Equally symbolic will be the New Artist award, where insiders expect Christina Aguilera and, yes, Britney Spears to fight it out for top honors. One shouldn't be too hard on the current teen pop idol.
还有《Supernatural》的年度最佳专辑。同样具有象征意义的是新人奖，业内人士预计克里斯蒂娜·阿奎莱拉和布兰妮·斯皮尔斯将争夺最高荣誉。人不应该对当前的青少年流行偶像太苛刻。
Yeah, Dad.
是啊，爸爸。
At least she didn't have to make talk on Who  Wants to Marry a Millionaire?
至少她不必在《谁想嫁给百万富翁》上谈话。
Here's our exit.
这是我们的出口。
You missed it?
你错过了吗？
No, here it is.
不，就在这儿。
Oh. Almost there. Come on.
哦。快到了。快点。
All right, here we are.
好了，我们到了。
There's Pam.
那是帕姆。
So are you going to put your skates on in there?
所以你要在里面穿上溜冰鞋吗？
Yep.
是的。
I guess I'll just come in with you, because of the parent meeting. I'm going to bring the tape recorder, and I'm going to dance and sing.
我想我还是和你一起进去吧，因为有家长会。我要带上录音机，我要跳舞和唱歌。
No, leave it here.
不，把它留在这儿。
For the team? I just want to do a little number for them tonight.
为了团队？我只想今晚为他们表演一段小节目。
No, you're going to leave it here.
不，你要把它留在这儿。
I have a Christina Aguilera impression I want to do.
我有我想要模仿的克里斯蒂娜·阿奎莱拉。
No, no.
不，不。
[MUSIC - "SATISFACTION" BY CAT POWER]
[音乐 - 猫力（Cat Power）的《SATISFACTION》]
Coming up, David Sedaris with a special message for young people about what happens when you get high and get into a car with your own mother. And adventures on the way to Hubcap City. That's in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，大卫·塞达里斯将给年轻人传达一个特别的信息，关于当你吸食毒品后和你自己的母亲一起上车会发生什么。还有通往轮毂盖城的冒险。一会儿就到，来自国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. It's often said that this country was rebuilt in the 20th century to accommodate automobiles. Because of cars, we have the suburbs, the malls, the highway system, much of the physical and commercial structure of this country. And so, if cars are so important, today's program is made up entirely of stories that happen in cars.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。人们常说这个国家在20世纪是为了适应汽车而重建的。因为汽车，我们有了郊区、购物中心、高速公路系统，以及这个国家大部分的物理和商业结构。所以，如果汽车如此重要，今天的节目就完全由发生在车里的故事组成。
Outside Washington, DC, a couple times a week, in an '88 Mercury Grand Marquis that he inherited from his mother, Senator Conrad Burns of Montana picks up random passengers from Virginia, drives them into the city during his rush hour commute. Having people in the car means that he can drive in the fast lanes that are set aside for cars that are full. He told me that the conversations also let him know what issues are on people's minds.
在华盛顿特区外，每周几次，在他从母亲那里继承的88年水星大侯爵车里，蒙大拿州的参议员康拉德·伯恩斯从弗吉尼亚州接载随机乘客，在上下班高峰期开车带他们进入市区。车里有人意味着他可以在那些留给满载车辆的快速车道上行驶。他告诉我，这些谈话也让他知道人们心中关心的问题。
Politicians, I think, have a big problem. They've never learned the lesson that you can't hear with your mouth open. You know, it's interesting what people talk about, especially-- But they'll always notice, sometimes they notice the Montana plates and they'll say, well, you're from Montana? And I said, yeah, I'm native. They ask what I do. And sometimes I sort of just don't answer or I give them some sort of a nondescript answer.
政客，我认为，有一个大问题。他们从未学到教训，那就是你不能在张着嘴的时候听。你知道，人们谈论的事情很有趣，尤其是——但他们总是会注意到，有时他们注意到蒙大拿的车牌，他们会说，哦，你来自蒙大拿？我说，是的，我是本地人。他们问我做什么。有时我只是不回答，或者给他们某种不具体的回答。
Wait, wait. Is the nondescript answer-- Do you just say, I work in the government, something like that?
等等，等等。这个不具体的回答是——你只是说，我在政府工作，类似这样吗？
I work on the Hill. I tell them I'm one of the ants on the Hill.
我在国会山工作。我告诉他们我是山上的蚂蚁之一。
More or less accurate.
差不多准确。
I would say.
我会这么说。
In a taxicab in New york City, Jeff Perkins tape-records his passengers on a little cassette machine, just to pass the time. He's collected hundreds of hours of tape.
在纽约市的一辆出租车里，杰夫·珀金斯用一台小型磁带机录下他的乘客，只是为了打发时间。他收集了数百小时的磁带。
Well, I'm trying to kind of focus on a particular subject which I'd like to ask you about.
好吧，我试着专注于一个我想问你的特定主题。
OK.
好的。
And the subject is the subject of dreaming. And I'd like to know if you dream vividly, or do you remember your dreams?
这个主题是梦的主题。我想知道你是否做生动的梦，或者你记得你的梦吗？
Sometimes I do remember them. Actually, when I was in my early 20s, I was having a recurrent dream of my family being edible. I had dreamt once that my mother was a Fig Newton and that I was dating Mr. Nabisco. And I also recall dreaming that my father's feet were made of roast beef, and that he would sit in his usual chair and slice off pieces of his roast beef feet to feed us with.
有时我确实记得它们。事实上，我在20岁出头时，经常做梦梦见我的家人是可以食用的。我曾经梦见过我母亲是一个无花果牛顿饼干，而我正在和纳比斯克先生约会。我还记得梦见我父亲的脚是烤牛肉做的，他会坐在他平时坐的椅子上，切下他烤牛肉脚的碎片来喂我们。
On the other side of the country, where dreams come true, Los Angeles. Cars scoot along the 405 and the 10. When Rob Levine first came out west, he got his first Hollywood job in one of those cars, a mid-1980s BMW 5 series, big heavy car. He as the driver for a movie producer named Edgar Sherick, who was the head of ABC back in the '60s, went on to produce lots of films. Heartbreak Kid , The Stepford Wives, Mrs. Soffel , Woody Allen's first movie, Take the Money and Run. Driver, in this world, can be a job where you train to be a movie producer yourself, which Rob Levine wanted. So he not only took care of the car, he read every script, sat in on meetings, learned everything.
在国家的另一端，梦想成真的地方，洛杉矶。汽车在405号和10号公路上穿梭。当罗伯·莱文第一次来到西部时，他在其中一辆车里得到了他的第一份好莱坞工作，那是一辆80年代中期的宝马5系，大型重型车。他是电影制片人埃德加·谢里克的司机，埃德加·谢里克在60年代是ABC的负责人，后来制作了很多电影。《心碎小子》、《斯戴福妻子》、《索菲夫人》、伍迪·艾伦的第一部电影《傻瓜大闹科学城》。在这个世界里，司机可以是一份让你训练自己成为电影制片人的工作，这也是罗伯·莱文想要的。所以他不仅照顾车，还读了每一个剧本，旁听了会议，学会了一切。
Part of the idea was that I would shadow him. I was expected to know everything he was reading. I was expected to know who he was calling and why. And he would ask me routinely, why am I calling this person? And not just to test me, because he honestly would slip his mind, and I would have to know.
想法的一部分是我会跟随他。我被期望了解他在读的所有东西。我被期望知道他在给谁打电话以及为什么。他会习惯性地问我，为什么我要给这个人打电话？不仅仅是为了测试我，因为他真的会忘记，而我必须知道。
Wait. He would say, dial the phone for me, why am I calling?
等等。他会说，帮我拨电话，我为什么打电话？
Yeah, why am I calling this person? And I would have to sort of, because you want to ask him about this project or that project. So if you didn't know, it was, you're in big trouble.
是的，为什么我要给这个人打电话？而我必须像这样，因为你想问他关于这个项目或那个项目的事情。所以如果你不知道，那就意味着你会有大麻烦。
Were you a little scared of him?
你有点怕他吗？
Oh yeah. Oh yeah, completely. I mean, he was a sort of larger-than-life figure. At that point, he smoked big Cuban cigars, which we'd have to get for him. It was sort of contraband, and we had to get them from Cuba.
哦是的。哦是的，完全是。我的意思是，他是一个某种程度上超越现实的人物。当时，他抽大雪茄，我们必须为他弄到。这是一种走私品，我们必须从古巴弄到。
That was part of your job?
那是你工作的一部分吗？
Oh yeah. Yeah, we had to get them from South Africa, which is like a double no-no.
哦是的。是的，我们必须从南非弄到，这就像是双重禁忌。
Wait. So because this is during the embargo?
等等。所以因为这是在禁运期间？
It's during Apartheid, yeah. So not only are you getting contraband cigars, you're getting them through a country that you didn't want to be doing business with. Sometimes we would get them through Canada, too.
这是在种族隔离期间，是的。所以你不仅是在弄走私雪茄，你还是通过一个你不希望与之做生意的国家来弄到它们。有时我们也通过加拿大弄到。
Which brings us to this story. Some people do their socializing in the car, just cruising around, running errands with friends, seeing who's out. In a 1991 Toyota Camry, Ernest Castle, a college student, tools around with his friend, Clarence, in the south Chicago suburb where they both grew up, where they both still live with their parents, Hazel Crest.
这就引出了这个故事。有些人是在车里社交，只是四处兜风，和朋友跑腿，看看谁在外面。在一辆1991年的丰田凯美瑞里，大学生欧内斯特·卡索和他的朋友克拉伦斯一起开着车，在他们长大的芝加哥南郊，他们现在还和父母住在那里，黑兹尔克雷斯特。
Sittin' up in here, early Sunday morning. Damn, it must be about 8 o'clock in the morning.
坐在这里，周日一大早。该死，现在大概是早上8点钟了。
Yeah, it's something like that. [INAUDIBLE] 3:30, he's done, mostly.
是的，大概是这样。[听不清] 3:30，他做完了，大部分。
This is about as close as it gets on a Sunday. Kind of one of them slow Sundays, on the way to ABC--
这是周日能做到的最接近的事情。这是一种缓慢的周日，在去ABC的路上——
Auto  Parts.
汽车零部件。
Yeah, Auto Parts. You know what I'm saying? To go get a hubcap.
是的，汽车零部件。你知道我在说什么吗？去弄个轮毂盖。
Oh, now you're going to Hubcap City. That's right across the street--
哦，现在你要去轮毂盖城了。就在街对面——
My friend, Clarence, OK, my boy. What clicks between me and Clarence is we're from the same exact place. We're from the same block. We grew up about 600 steps away from each other. We're brothers.
我的朋友，克拉伦斯，好的，我的兄弟。我和克拉伦斯之间合拍的是我们来自同一个地方。我们来自同一个街区。我们长大时离彼此大概只有600步的距离。我们是兄弟。
Damn, look at this cat. They gotta be some Mexicans, man.
该死，看看这个家伙。他们一定是墨西哥人，伙计。
It was. It was. Some kings or something, just with the low-profile tires. Them's about 13s or 12s, so you know he's riding low. The car was, like, about two inches off the ground. And it was just flicking away, painted rims. it was a Neon, but he did the Neon justice, though. He did it justice. I'm going to give him the credit on that one.
是的。是的。一些国王之类的，只是装了低调的轮胎。那是13或12英寸的，所以你知道他开得很低。车离地面只有大概两英寸。而且它就在闪烁，轮圈喷了漆。这是一辆尼桑，但他确实没亏待这辆尼桑。他没亏待它。我要在这点上给他加分。
Clarence and I, we're definitely trying to do two different things. He's definitely the street-savvy, basically hustler. And me? I'm trying to do my thing in other ways. You know what I'm saying? I'm going to school, right? So that basically keeps us apart for most of the week. But when we come together on the weekend, it all comes together basically in the car. We got the radio. We got the tapes. A couple of beers, a couple of drinks. That's basically the quality of life for us, man.
克拉伦斯和我，我们确实在尝试做两件不同的事情。他绝对是街头智慧，基本上是个骗子。而我？我正在尝试用其他方式做我的事情。你知道我在说什么吗？我在上学，对吧？所以这基本上让我们在一周的大部分时间里分开了。但当我们周末聚在一起时，它基本上都在车里合体了。我们有收音机。我们有磁带。几杯啤酒，几杯饮料。这基本上就是我们的生活质量，伙计。
Ooh, that's a nice-ass Chevy. You see that Chevy with the gold rims over there?
哦，那是一辆漂亮的雪佛兰。你看到那边那辆装有金轮圈的雪佛兰了吗？
Oh, man.
哦，伙计。
Gold flicks.
金色闪光。
Damn.
该死。
Now, that's a black man driving that probably. You know what I'm saying? Everybody representing in their own way. Without a doubt. That's how different this [BLEEP] is. You see what I'm saying? Our Mexican people like they're [BLEEP] low. You know what I'm saying? Brothers like their [BLEEP] high. Mexicans get, like, smaller rims. Brothers get rims that are too damn big for their car. You know what I'm saying? For real. You know what I'm saying?
现在，那个开车的可能是一个黑人。你知道我在说什么吗？每个人都以自己的方式展示。毫无疑问。这就是这玩意儿有多不同。你看到我在说什么了吗？我们的墨西哥人喜欢他们的玩意儿开得很低。你知道我在说什么吗？兄弟们喜欢他们的玩意儿开得很高。墨西哥人喜欢，像是更小的轮圈。兄弟们喜欢那些对他们的车来说太大该死的轮圈。你知道我在说什么吗？真的。你知道我在说什么吗？
OK, we're rolling along and run into some childhood buddies here. Now, these guys, they're known in the neighborhood. They're known in the neighborhood. You mostly see them all in a group, at least I do. And we roll up on them, and thery see the microphone, and basically everything comes out.
好的，我们开着车，在这里遇到了一些儿时的伙伴。现在，这些人，他们在社区里很有名。他们在社区里很有名。你通常看到他们都是一群，至少我是这样。我们开车上去，他们看到麦克风，基本上所有东西都出来了。
[BLEEP] the police. [BLEEP] the DEA. You know, they [BLEEP] with me for no rhyme or reason, you know? I'm tired of this bull [BLEEP].
[哔]警察。 [哔]缉毒局。你知道，他们[哔]我没有任何原因，你知道吗？我厌倦了这种胡扯。
Now, these guys, they've had their run-ins with the law. They've got their little histories, juvenile cases, whatever, what have you. But these guys, let's just say they tend to exaggerate a little bit.
现在，这些人，他们和法律发生过冲突。他们有他们的小历史，青少年案件，无论什么，诸如此类。但这些人，我们只能说他们倾向于夸大一点。
What Marshall was talking about, he was talking about how they was-- Man, he went on into a tangent about getting beat down by the police. But he made it sound like every time he stepped outside the house--
马歇尔在说什么，他在说他们是怎么——伙计，他偏离了轨道，谈论被警察打倒。但他让它听起来像他每次走出房子——
Exactly. I think people that got too wrapped up into the movies, into the tapes they play, and they feel, because of the people on the tapes and in the movies get harassed by the police, that they are really getting harassed. They're not getting harassed, man. Police just came around the corner. Man, we should go around there and see what their business is, yo.
完全正确。我认为那些太沉迷于电影、他们播放的磁带的人，他们觉得，因为磁带和电影里的人被警察骚扰，他们真的被警察骚扰了。他们没被骚扰，伙计。警察刚才刚过拐角。伙计，我们应该去那边看看他们的事，哟。
Hey, whatever.
嘿，随便。
Oh, they're real. Let's be on some investigative reporter type [BLEEP].
哦，他们是真的。让我们去做些调查记者的活儿。
And so me and Clarence, we decide to conduct our own little case study here.
所以我和克拉伦斯决定在这里进行我们自己的小案例研究。
Right now we are busting the U-turn, trying to see if the police is really gonna go and hassle them like they said they was. This whole conversation was about police harassment, profiling, this and that, which is definitely, definitely, definitely real. But we about to see.
现在我们正在掉头，试图看看警察是否真的会像他们说的那样去骚扰他们。整个谈话是关于警察骚扰、定性等等，这绝对、绝对、绝对是真实的。但我们要看看。
The police roll right by 'em.
警察直接从他们身边开过。
Zoom.
嗖。
Right by 'em.
直接开过。
Zoom.
嗖。
No confrontations, no nothing.
没有对抗，什么都没有。
Zoom. And this car parked on the wrong side of the street at that, to draw attention.
嗖。而且这辆车还停在街道错误的一侧，为了引起注意。
And the police roll right by 'em.
警察直接从他们身边开过。
Zoom.
嗖。
There he is.
他在那儿。
There's the policeman right there.
警察就在那儿。
I don't know how to call it, man. You know what I'm saying? When the microphone turn on, people got a lot of stuff to say, and a lot to talk about. But once it turn off, the mother [BLEEP] go back to their everyday, dull-ass life. He want to portray some sort of lifestyle, like he's being, I don't know, railroaded into the life that he's living.
我不知道怎么说，伙计。你知道我在说什么吗？当麦克风打开时，人们有很多东西要说，有很多要谈的。但一旦关掉，这帮混蛋就回到他们每天沉闷的生活中去了。他想描绘某种生活方式，就像他被，我不知道，被逼进了他正在过的生活中。
I just feel that he's not doing what he feels he's capable of doing. And that's all of us out here. I'll be damned, we livin' in the suburbs. You know what I'm saying? I mean, me, myself, and the situation I'm in, is because of the life I have lived since I was a kid, coming up. I really wasn't on my P's and Q's. You know what I'm saying? I've been messing up for a nice long amount of time now, to keep it real. That's just how it is. You know what I'm saying?
我只是觉得他没有做他觉得他有能力做的事。而这就是我们外面所有的人。该死，我们住在郊区。你知道我在说什么吗？我的意思是，我自己，以及我所处的环境，是因为我从小到大过的生活。我真的没有注意我的言行。你知道我在说什么吗？我已经搞砸了很长一段时间了，说实话。事实就是这样。你知道我在说什么吗？
For the average mainstream person, middle class and up, they're looking at Clarence, and they're like, oh lord, here comes another wild off-the-hook street thug, ready to do whatever he has to do, wreak havoc, kill, shoot, whatever. But that's not the case at all. The way I see it, it's just like the movie, Slackers. Here's the guy who, he has goals, but he's a procrastinator. He'll sit on his butt until the last minute, and try to do something. He's a slacker. Everybody knows what a slacker is.
对于普通的主流人士，中产阶级及以上，他们看着克拉伦斯，他们就像，哦天哪，又来了一个狂野的街头暴徒，准备好做他必须做的任何事，造成浩劫、杀人、射击，无论什么。但根本不是这样。在我看来，这就像电影《懒虫》。这就是那个有目标，但他是个拖延者的家伙。他会坐在屁股上直到最后一分钟，并试图做点什么。他是个懒虫。每个人都知道懒虫是什么。
He just does the little things that he has to to keep a little bit of money in his pocket. And we're all slackers. I mean, I can't even say anything because I'm a slacker myself. But from his perspective, where he's coming from, to be a slacker, you're a hustler in the same breath.
他只是做他必须做的那些小事来让口袋里有一点钱。我们都是懒虫。我的意思是，我甚至不能说什么，因为我自己也是个懒虫。但从他的角度来看，他从哪里来，要成为一个懒虫，你在同一时间也是一个骗子。
It's a ditch, man. Oh, shit. See, that's professional driving right there. You've got to know the limitations and the proper mechanical, um-- Ah, the hell with it. It was a nice turn. It was a very nice turn, on my part. I pat myself on the back.
那是一个沟渠，伙计。哦，该死。看，那是专业的驾驶。你必须知道限制和正确的机械，呃——啊，去他的吧。那是一个不错的转弯。那是一个非常不错的转弯，我做得很好。我拍拍自己的背。
We're passing by this junkyard, right? And I see this "Now Hiring" sign posted up on this 13-foot iron gate. Huge sign, with crimson-embroidered letters, "Now Hiring." I look up at Clarence. And I know he's not going to go for this, but I gotta mention it 'cause that's me. And I'm like, you know, how about the "Now Hiring" sign, figuring this is his opportunity to finally get a job with a tax return that'll keep him from a fair amount of trouble, let's just say.
我们经过这个废品场，对吧？我看到这个“现正招聘”的标志贴在那个13英尺高的铁门上。巨大的标志，绣着深红色的字母，“现正招聘”。我抬头看着克拉伦斯。我知道他不会赞同，但我必须提一下，因为那是我的风格。我就说，你知道，那个“现正招聘”的标志怎么样，以为这是他终于得到一份报税的工作的机会，这将使他远离相当多的麻烦，我们这么说吧。
They all be hiring.
他们都在招聘。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You're going to try to call it out for me. Get a job.
你要试图把它说出来给我听。找份工作。
Now, see, I ain't say nothin' about you. See, that's you. That's you over there.
现在，你看，我没说关于你的任何事。看，那是你。那是那边那个你。
That's all I'm saying.
我只是这么说。
Look at that big man across the fence, man.
看看篱笆那边那个大个子，伙计。
I see it, though.
我看得到，虽然。
Now hiring.
现正招聘。
I understand that. I understand that, you know what I'm saying?
我理解。我理解，你知道我在说什么吗？
Basically, I think where the fork in the road took place between my life and Clarence's life, it's as simple as he went to public school and I went to a Catholic school outside of my city. Sealed me away up in there, got me in all of these activities. I had no time, basically, in my schedule to get in the streets until the weekend. By the weekend, everybody did their dirt in the week already.
基本上，我认为分岔路出现在我的生活和克拉伦斯的生活之间，简单来说就是他上了公立学校，我上了城市外面的一所天主教学校。把我封在那里，让我参加所有这些活动。我的日程基本上没有时间在周末之前进入街头。到周末，每个人都已经在一周内做完了他们的坏事。
Meanwhile, with Clarence, when we were in high school, basically everything opened up. You got your gangs, your different street factions, and it was shiny, like a brand-new golden apple. It was just the street ambrosia. You live forever. I mean, who wouldn't have wanted to be a part of it? I wanted to be a part of it. Neither of us were brains, so I guess he chose an easier route, an easier road.
与此同时，和克拉伦斯一起，当我们上高中的时候，基本上一切都打开了。你有你的帮派，你不同的街头派系，它是闪亮的，像一个崭新的金苹果。它简直就是街头的仙果。你永生。我的意思是，谁不想成为它的一部分呢？我想成为它的一部分。我们俩都不是天才，所以我猜他选择了一条更简单的路，一条更简单的路。
And in the same predicament, to walk a mile in Clarence's shoes, I'd have took it, without a doubt, without a doubt, without a doubt.
在同样的困境中，站在克拉伦斯的角度考虑，我也会接受的，毫无疑问，毫无疑问，毫无疑问。
All right, we here at Hubcap City. This is a big junkyard, basically.
好的，我们到了轮毂盖城。这基本上是一个大废品场。
Is that a Buick or some [BLEEP]. It's got new tires on it so it must run.
那是别克还是什么[哔]。它装了新轮胎，所以它一定能开。
That's what they want you to believe.
那是他们想让你相信的。
Probably so. Probably so.
可能如此。可能如此。
At any go it is, let's see if I can't get a damn hubcap.
不管怎样，看看我能不能弄到一个该死的轮毂盖。
[MUSIC - "PASSENGER SIDE" BY WILCO]
[音乐 - 威洛（Wilco）的《PASSENGER SIDE》]
Some of the most important moments of people's lives happen in cars, though sometimes we are not aware that these are the most important moments in our lives as they're happening. David Sedaris tells this story.
人们生活中一些最重要的时刻发生在车里，尽管有时我们并没有意识到这些是我们生命中发生的最重要的时刻。大卫·塞达里斯讲述了这个故事。
It wasn't anything I'd planned on, but at the age of 22, after dropping out of my second college and traveling back and forth across the country a few times, I found myself back in Raleigh, North Carolina, living in my parents' basement. After I'd spent six months waking at noon, getting high, and listening to the same Joni Mitchell record over and over again, my father called me into his den and told me to get out. He was sitting very formally in a big comfortable chair behind his desk. And I felt as though he was firing me from the job of being his son.
这不是我计划中的任何事情，但在22岁时，在从我的第二所大学退学并在这个国家来回旅行了几次后，我发现自己回到了北卡罗来纳州的罗利，住在我父母的地下室里。在我花了六个月的时间在中午醒来、吸毒、反复听同一张琼尼·米切尔的唱片后，我父亲把我叫进他的书房，告诉我离开。他非常正式地坐在他书桌后一张舒适的大椅子里。我觉得他就像是在解雇我作为一个儿子的工作。
I'd seen this coming, and it honestly didn't bother me all that much. The way I saw it, being kicked out of the house was just what I needed if I was ever going to get back on my feet. Fine, I said. I'll go, but one day you'll be sorry. I had no idea what I meant by that. It just seemed like the sort of thing a person should say when they were told to leave.
我预料到了这一点，它老实说并没有太困扰我。在我看来，被赶出家门正是我重新站起来所需要的。好的，我说。我会走的，但总有一天你会后悔的。我不知道我那是什么意思。那只是当一个人被告知要离开时应该说的那种话。
My sister, Lisa, had an apartment over by the university, and said I could come stay with her as long as I didn't bring my Joni Mitchell record. My mother offered to drive me over. And after a few bong hits, I took her up on it. It was a 15-minute ride across town, and on the way my mother and I listened to the rebroadcast of a radio call-in show, in which people phoned the host to describe the various birds gathered around their backyard feeders.
我姐姐丽莎在大学那边有一套公寓，说我可以去和她住，只要我不带我的琼尼·米切尔唱片。我妈妈提议开车送我过去。在吸了几口大麻后，我接受了她的好意。那是一段穿过城镇15分钟的旅程，在路上，我和我妈妈听了一个广播电话节目的重播，人们打电话给主持人描述聚集在他们后院喂食器周围的各种鸟类。
Normally, the show came on in the morning, and it seemed strange to listen to it at night. The birds in question had gone to bed hours ago, and probably had no idea they were still being talked about. I thought about this and wondered if anyone back at the house was talking about me. To the best of my knowledge, no one had ever tried to describe my voice or the shape of my head. And it depressed me that I went unnoticed while people were willing to drop everything for a cardinal.
通常，这个节目是在早上播放的，而在晚上听它看起来很奇怪。相关的鸟儿几小时前已经睡觉了，可能根本不知道还在谈论它们。我想到了这一点，并想知道家里是否有人在谈论我。据我所知，从来没有人试图描述我的声音或我的头型。这让我感到沮丧，因为我被忽视了，而人们却愿意为了红雀放下一切。
My mother pulled up in front of my sister's apartment. And when I opened the car door, she started to cry, which worried me because she normally didn't do things like that. It wasn't one of those, I'm going to miss you things, but something deeper and sadder than that. I wouldn't know it until months later, but my father had kicked me out of the house not because I was a bum, but because I was gay. Our little talk was supposed to be one of those defining moments that shape a person's adult life, but he'd been so uncomfortable with the most important word that he'd left it out completely, saying only, I think we both know why I'm doing this. I'd assumed it was because of the drugs, and had left it at that. I guess I could've nailed him down. I just hadn't seen the point.
我妈妈停在我姐姐公寓前。当我打开车门时，她开始哭泣，这让我很担心，因为她通常不做那种事。那不是那种“我会想念你”的事，而是比那更深、更悲伤的东西。我直到几个月后才知道，我父亲赶我出家门不是因为我是一个流浪汉，而是因为我是同性恋。我们的小谈话本应该是塑造一个人成年生活的决定性时刻之一，但他对这个最重要的词感到如此不舒服，以至于他完全忽略了它，只说，我想我们都知道我为什么要这样做。我以为这是因为毒品，就这样算了。我想我本可以逼问他的。我只是没看到重点。
My mother assumed that I knew the truth, and it tore her up. Here was another defining moment, and again I missed it completely. She cried until it sounded as if she were choking. I'm sorry, she said. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I figured that within a few weeks, I'd have a job and some crummy little apartment. It didn't seem insurmountable, but my mother's tears made me worry that finding these things might be a little harder than I thought.
我妈妈以为我知道真相，这让她心碎。这是另一个决定性时刻，我又完全错过了它。她哭得听起来好像她在窒息。对不起，她说。对不起。对不起。对不起。我以为几周内我就会有一份工作和一套破旧的小公寓。这看起来并非无法克服，但我妈妈的眼泪让我担心找到这些东西可能比我想象的要难一点。
Did she honestly think I was that much of a loser? Really, I said. I'll be fine. The car light was on, and I wondered what the passing drivers thought as they watched my mother sob. What kind of people did they think we were? Did they think she was one of those crybaby moms who fell apart every time someone chipped a coffee cup? Did they assume I'd said something to hurt her? Did they see us as just another crying mother and her stoned gay son, sitting in a station wagon and listening to a call-in show about birds? Or did they imagine, for just one moment, that we might be special?
她真的认为我是那么失败的人吗？真的，我说。我会没事的。车里的灯亮着，我好奇当经过的司机看着我妈妈抽泣时在想什么。他们认为我们是什么样的人？他们认为她是那种每次有人碰坏咖啡杯就会崩溃的爱哭妈妈吗？他们以为我说了一些伤害她的话吗？他们是否把我们视为另一个哭泣的母亲和她吸了毒的同性恋儿子，坐在旅行车里听关于鸟类的电话节目？还是他们想象，哪怕只是一瞬间，我们可能是特别的？
Dave Sedaris' latest book is called Me Talk Pretty One Day.
戴夫·塞达里斯的最新书名为《我谈得很漂亮的一天》。
[MUSIC - "I WANT A LAVENDAR CADILLAC" BY MAURICE KING AND HIS WOLVERINES]
[音乐 - 莫里斯·金和他的狼獾乐队的《I WANT A LAVENDAR CADILLAC》]
There are people out on the road with no other purpose but to help others, as if the streets and highways are like the open sea, dangerous and unpredictable, thousands of motorists stranded at any given moment, needing saviors. And there's a little yellow pickup truck, AAA insignia on the door, tool cases in the back.
在路上有一些人的唯一目的是帮助他人，好像街道和高速公路就像公海一样，危险且不可预测，成千上万的司机在任何时候被困，需要救星。有一辆黄色的小皮卡车，车门上有AAA标志，后面有工具箱。
370.
370。
Yes, 370. Good morning.
是的，370。早上好。
Good morning. Did you say you had a service call holding?
早上好。你说你有服务电话在等候吗？
Yeah, we have a T3 on Prospect. Do you want me to send that over?
是的，我们在Prospect有一个T3。你想让我把它发过去吗？
Yeah, 10-4. Prospect, where the [BLEEP] is that?
是的，10-4。Prospect，那玩意儿在哪儿啊？
Kelly Keggers wears dark blue pants and a button-down AAA service shirt. The dispatch computer on her dashboard lists AAA members in trouble.
凯利·凯格斯穿着深蓝色的裤子和一件扣领AAA服务衬衫。她仪表盘上的调度电脑列出了遇到麻烦的AAA会员。
Well, all I do all day is go out and help people. It's like community service. People call when they're in need, if their car doesn't start, or if they've got a flat tire, or they run out of gas or something. If their car's not working, they call. It's all day.
嗯，我整天做的就是出去帮助别人。这就像社区服务。当人们有需要时打电话，如果他们的车启动不了，或者如果他们轮胎瘪了，或者他们没油了之类的。如果他们的车不工作，他们就打电话。这是一整天。
And everytime I show up, people are like all, oh my god, you're here. It's like I'm all doing them a favor or something. It's a good deed job. Early in the morning, though, it's, like, jump-starts, but pretty much people lock their keys in their car. They're getting ready for work, and they're freaking out and-- Oh, here comes my member. What's happening with your car? It won't start?
而且每次我出现，人们都像，天哪，你在这儿。这就像我在为他们做人情一样。这是一个善举工作。不过清晨，是那种，跳线启动，但基本上人们把钥匙锁在车里。他们准备去上班，他们吓坏了，而且——哦，我的会员来了。你的车怎么了？它不启动？
Battery's dead. I keep switching the lights on because it--
电池没电了。我一直开着灯，因为它——
Her horn did-- like, you know, lights are on the blinker of your car, like if you put the blinker up or down? A lot of people complain about the new Hondas. They turn the blinker on during the day, they're coming home from, blah, blah, blah, whatever, and they leave their lights on all night long. And there's no buzzer or anything to tell them that their frickin' lights are on.
她的喇叭确实——像，你知道，灯在你的车转向灯上，像如果你向上或向下拨转向灯？很多人抱怨新的本田。他们在白天开转向灯，他们从别的地方回家，等等，不管什么，他们把灯整晚都开着。而且没有任何蜂鸣器或其他东西告诉他们他们该死的灯开着。
So she's all pissed off about that. And she was worried about her battery, but it's a brand-new car. It's a 1999. Oh, wait. Let me get these calls.
所以她对那个很生气。她担心她的电池，但这是一辆全新的车。它是1999年的。哦，等等。让我接这些电话。
I have three more service calls. Two of them are kind of a ways away, I think. We have this 6 at Third and Cargo. Three at Gillman, and Raymond and Redland.
我有三个以上的服务电话。我想其中两个有点远。我们在第三和Cargo有6。Gillman有3，还有Raymond和Redland。
OK, I can do all three of those. That's cool. Go ahead and send them my way.
好的，我可以做那三个。那很酷。继续把它们发给我。
10-4. Copy that.
10-4。复制那个。
I love driving around without a boss in the car with me. I don't like to work with-- I'm not really much of a team player, I guess.
我喜欢在没有老板在车里的情况下开车。我不喜欢和——我想我不是那种团队合作者。
On West 7th?
在西7街？
I don't like to work with people that much. I just like to work by myself and do my own thing. I just get things done faster and better that way. I guess I can just concentrate by myself. I mean, I like helping people, though. I get a kick out of it. It's kind of a good feeling.
我不喜欢和人合作那么多。我只是喜欢自己工作，做我自己的事。我那样做事更快更好。我想我一个人可以集中精力。我的意思是，我喜欢帮助别人，虽然。我从中得到乐趣。这是一种很好的感觉。
We've got a cancel on our Hazelwood and Rosewood. The member found her keys.
我们在Hazelwood和Rosewood的电话取消了。会员找到了她的钥匙。
Cops wave at me when I drive by. Buses stop and let me go by them. It's weird. All city workers are always like, hey, how's it going? Oh, AAA. Hi. You know, waving. And people flag me down a lot when I'm driving. Or if they need a jump-start or whatever, they jump in front of your car with jumper cables. I'm going 40. They fly in front of the truck. You're like, [BRAKING SOUNDS], oh crap. But, no, they treat me really good. They're really nice. I don't get treated like a punk kid, like I usually do.
我开车经过时警察对我招手。公交车停下来让我经过。这很奇怪。所有的城市工作人员总是像，嘿，怎么样？哦，AAA。嗨。你知道，招手。当我在开车时，人们经常向我招手示意。或者如果他们需要跳线启动或什么的，他们跳到你的车前拿着跳线。我开40。他们飞到卡车前。你就像，[刹车声]，哦该死。但是，不，他们对我很好。他们真的很友善。我不像平时那样被当作朋克小孩对待。
I jump-started some guy's car on 21st, oh no, it was 22nd street, and there's a big, huge hill. And it was a stick shift, and I told him to keep his foot on the brake. And he didn't, of course. And he was an older guy. And I mean, right as soon as his car started, he took his foot off the brake to get out of the car, and it stalled because it was a stick shift and all that. And it went sailing down the street. And it slammed into a tree and totalled his car. It almost ran me over. I jumped out of the way. I pulled a total, like, Dukes of Hazard.
我在21街给某个人的车跳线启动，哦不，那是22街，那里有一个又大又高的坡。它是手动挡的，我告诉他把脚踩在刹车上。当然他没做。他是一个年纪较大的人。我的意思是，就在他的车启动时，他把脚从刹车上拿下来想下车，它熄火了，因为它是手动挡等等。它就向街下滑去。它撞上了一棵树，把他的车撞废了。它差点把我撞死。我跳开了。我完成了一个彻底的，像《危险公爵》一样的动作。
And of course we had to call a tow truck for that. But it wasn't my fault. It was his fault. I advised him not to take his foot off the brake, and blah, blah, blah. But he was old and he was a little grumpy. He's like, I know what to do. His wife started screaming at him. It was really upsetting. I sat with him for a while. He was shaken up. He was scared. He was still in the car. I mean, he tried to get out but he couldn't.
当然我们不得不给那个叫拖车。但那不是我的错。是他的错。我建议他不要把脚从刹车上拿下来，等等。但他年纪大，而且有点脾气暴躁。他说，我知道该怎么做。他的妻子开始对他尖叫。那真的很令人不安。我和他坐了一会儿。他被吓坏了。他很害怕。他还在车里。我的意思是，他试图下车但他下不来。
Yeah, that was my big excitement for one day. But everything else is pretty normal. I mean, you get babies locked in cars and stuff. People are freaking out. I try and get there really fast if there's a baby in the car. So I always do that as a priority.
是的，那是我的大兴奋一天。但其他一切都很正常。我的意思是，你有锁在车里的婴儿之类的。人们吓坏了。如果车里有婴儿，我会尝试很快赶到那里。所以我总是把那个作为优先事项。
It's cool when you pull into a shopping center, a big parking lot, because you'll always get two or three calls. People will flag you down. And usually they have AAA. And you write them up.
当你驶入购物中心、大型停车场时很酷，因为你总会接到两三个电话。人们会向你招手。而且他们通常有AAA。你就给他们写单子。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] again. [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
[听不清] 又。 [听不清的短语]。
This parking lot is humongous. Hello. See, you're waiting out front.
这个停车场非常巨大。你好。看，你在前面等。
Well, yeah. Got them locked them inside. You know, on the supervisor side.
嗯，是的。把它们锁在里面了。你知道，在主管那边。
OK, the supervisor side, all right. I'm totally addicted to that getting paid for job performance. Because that way it doesn't make me resentful of the people I work with if they're not pulling their weight. I just figure, they did 10 calls today, and I did, like, 32 calls. I know that I'm getting paid for all the calls I'm doing. I can't deal with getting pissed off at people I work with. But I like all the guys I work with. They're nice guys. There's one or two other girls that work there.
好的，主管那边，好的。我完全沉迷于那种因工作表现而获得报酬。因为那样就不会让我对和我一起工作的人产生怨恨，如果他们没有尽到自己的责任的话。我只是想，他们今天打了10个电话，而我打了大概32个电话。我知道我因为我所做的一切电话而得到报酬。我无法处理对和我一起工作的人感到生气。但我喜欢我一起工作的所有家伙。他们是好人。那里还有一两个其他女孩在工作。
But those guys are cool. And plus, you talk to them. We're all talking about our jobs. And it gives me ideas about-- I like to change jobs a lot. I like to be a total jack of all trades and bounce around. I can only stand a job for, like, a year or two. Like, my next job, I'm going to be a truck driver. I'm going to drive the big rigs. That's my dream, just drive across country completely alone, get my dog and truck, and that's it, just listen to music and just drive.
但那些家伙很酷。而且加上，你和他们聊天。我们都在谈论我们的工作。这给了我关于——我喜欢经常换工作。我喜欢成为一个全才，四处跳跃。我只能忍受一份工作大概一年或两年。像，我的下一份工作，我要成为一名卡车司机。我要驾驶大型拖车。那是我的梦想，只是独自驾驶穿越全国，带上我的狗和卡车，就是这样，只是听音乐，只是开车。
This way, right? Third row? One, two-- he's all running. Poor guy.
这边，对吧？第三排？一，二——他都在跑。可怜的家伙。
Well, our program was produced today by Blue Chevigny and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors Potoff, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Mary Wiltenburg. Music help from Mr. John Connors. People in cars are recorded by Kerry Campbell, Bob Carlson, Elizabeth Meister, Blue Chevigny, Alex Blumberg, Kenneth Mason, and Piers Wisbey at the BBC. Jay Allison's story with his daughter, Lily, was part of his Life Stories series, which is funded by the Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
好了，我们的节目今天由布鲁·谢维尼和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、苏珊·伯顿和朱莉·斯奈德。特约编辑Potoff，杰克·希特，玛吉·罗奇林，阿利克斯·斯皮格尔，南希·厄普代克，以及顾问萨拉·沃威尔。托德·巴赫曼和玛丽·威尔滕伯格提供了制作帮助。约翰·康纳斯先生提供了音乐帮助。车里的人是由凯里·坎贝尔、鲍勃·卡尔森、伊丽莎白·迈斯特、布鲁·谢维尼、亚历克斯·布隆伯格、肯尼斯·梅森和皮尔斯·威斯贝在BBC录制的。杰伊·艾利森和他女儿莉莉的故事是他生活故事系列的一部分，该系列由公共广播公司资助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
To buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you know you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet, at our website, www.thislife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
要购买这个或我们任何节目的磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ，312-832-3380。或者你知道你可以在互联网上免费收听我们大部分的节目，在我们的网站上，www.thislife.org。美国生活由国际公共广播电台分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who begins every single broadcast of our program with this checklist:
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他以这个清单开始我们节目的每一场广播：
We got the radio, we got the tapes, a couple of beers, a couple of drinks.
我们有收音机，我们有磁带，几杯啤酒，几杯饮料。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。